GALLANT AND THAT SAYS A LOT.
JOHN: LET'S TALK SEATTLE KRAKEN.
WEEKESY WAS OUT THERE, CHUCKING
AND CATCHING FISH.
HE STILL STINKS.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB FRANCIS.
FROM HERE ON THE DRAFT -- SO
MANY BOARDS ARE SO VARIED.
THIS NEXT TWO TO 10 IT COULD GO
IN A MYRIAD OF WAYS.
BUT THE NAME WE KEEP HEARING,
SAM, AS YOU LOOK AT THE FORWARD
LINES AS THEY ARE CONSTRUCTED
AFTER THE EXPANSION DRAFT,
THINGS COULD STILL CHANGE.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOMEONE
LIKE A TEAMMATE OF OWEN POWER OR
MATTY BEN YERS.
BEN YERS HAS A LOT OF RUN.
SAM: WHEN WEEKESY CAME BACK.
I WAS TALKING TO EVERYBODY
THERE.
HE'S THE MAYOR HERE AND
EVERYWHERE.
HE SAYS WE WANT TO CREATE AN
IDENTITY.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
YOU TAKE MATTY BEN YERS WHO IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF WHAT A BLUE
COLLAR TOWN WOULD BE LIKE.
HE'S A GOOD-LOOKING DUDE.
HE'S EXTREMELY RESPONSIBLE.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF GUY YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR.
JOHN: THE PICK IS IN.
COMMISSIONER BETTMAN: FROM THE
SPACE NEEDLE IN SEATTLE, THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE SEATTLE
KRAKEN, RON FRANCIS WILL MAKE
THE SELECTION.
>> ON BEHALF OF OUR ENTIRE
OWNERSHIP GROUP, I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMISSIONER AND THE
31-MEMBER CLUBS FOR WELCOMING
THE SEATTLE KRAKEN INTO THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE.
ON BEHALF OF OUR PASSIONATE
FANS, I'M PROUD TO MAKE THE
HISTORIC FIRST EVER AMATEUR
SELECTION FOR OUR TEAM BY
CHOOSING FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN, MATTHEW BEN YERS.
-- BENIER, S.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN: MATTY BENIERS COMPLETE
CENTER.
MATCHUP CENTER GUY.
COULD BE A POWER PLAY GUY AS
WELL.
A GUY WHO MANY FEEL HE HAS A RUN
IN HIM, IS SELECTED BY RON
FRANCIS.
KEVIN: THERE'S SENIOR EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP AND SOME OF THE
COACHING STAFF.
THIS TEAM IS DOING EVERYTHING SO
WELL OFF THE ICE SO FAR.
I WAS BLOWN AWAY BY MY TIME OUT
THERE.
I HAD THE FEELING FROM SPEAKING
TO THEM, IF BENIERS WAS STILL
THERE, THEY WERE GOING TO TAKE
IT FOR ALL THE REASONS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MOLD, JOHN
THAN TOEWS WINS AT EVERYTHING.
WORLD JUNIOR, STANLEY CUBS.
OLYMPICS.
THAT'S WHERE THEY -- WORLD
JUNIORS, STANLEY CUP, THE
OLYMPICS.
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO SLEEP VERY
EASY WITH A CENTER ICEMAN LIKE
THAT.
>> GIVE ME 50% OF THAT AND I
WILL TAKE IT.
THIS KID IS A TERRIFIC PLAYER.
HE PLAYS THE WHOLE SHEET.
WELL-DOCUMENTED.
THIS IS A GREAT SELECTION FOR
SEATTLE.
THE ONLY THING THAT SURPRISED ME
IS THAT WEEKESY DIDN'T MAKE
PICK.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN: EXACTLY.
YOU DIDN'T RECORD THAT THE OTHER
NIGHT?
THOSE PIRATED VIDEOS.
KEVIN: IT WASN'T ME.
JOHN: EMILY CAPLIN IS WITH US.
SHE'S COVERING THE NHL
THROUGHOUT.
EMILY?
EMILY: RON FRANCIS JUST CALLED
HIM MATTHEW.
HE SAYS HE'S A MATTY.
HIS MOM WAS A BROADWAY ACTRESS
AND HE WAS A THEATER KID
HIMSELF.
NOW MORE OF AN ACADEMIC.
HE WAS SELECTED TO GO TO
HARVARD.
STUDIED PREMED AND INTERESTED IN
DERMATOLOGY.
LOVES THE SHOW "DR. PIMPLE
POPPER."
HE WEIGHED IN AT 168 POUNDS.
HE STRUGGLES TO PUT ON WAFPLGTE
THIS SUMMER HE FOCUSED ON
GAINING WEIGHT.
FIVE TO SIX MEALS A DAY.
5,000 CALORIES A DAY.
HE LOVES CHI POT LE.
THE REST IS EXTRA.
JOHN: WAS SET TO GO TO HARVARD.
MOM WENT TO CORNELL.
ENDS UP IN MICHIGAN.
GREAT RATINGS THE OTHER NIGHT,
KRAKEN FANS.
WHAT ARE THEY GETTING IN MATTY
BENIERS?
SAM: HE CAN PLAY THE FULL SHEET
OF THE ICE AS YOU MENTIONED.
BUT THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
MOMENTS.
THE FIRST WAS AT THE WORLD
JUNIORS.
HE LOOKS DEFENSIVELY RESPONSIBLE
RIGHT THERE.
NOW, I'LL TAKE THE PUCK AND GO.
TAKE IT ONE-ON-ONE INTO THE
ZONE.
BUT AT THE WORLD JUNE YORS HE
WAS USED IN HIGH LEVERAGE
SITUATIONS, TAKING KEY DRAWS
DOWN THE STRETCH.
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN FOR AN UNDER
AGE PLAYER AT THAT TOURNAMENT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE SUCCESS THAT
THE U.S. HAD IN WINNING THAT
TOURNAMENT.
AND THEN YOU THINK ABOUT, ALL
RIGHT, HE'S A LATE BIRTHDAY GUY.
THE WORLDS SAY, WHY DON'T YOU
COME WITH US?
AND HE DIDN'T QUITE REALLY CATCH
PACE THERE.
PLAYED A COUPLE MINUTES THERE.
BUT THE SIMPLE FACT THAT THEY
BROUGHT HIM, TELLS ME
EVERYTHING.
HE ENDED UP GETTING HURRY.
HE CAN BRING THAT IDENTITY FOR A
BRAND-NEW FRANCHISE.